un momento de dolor y homenaje
en París la agencia de noticias afp
rindió tributo a Hernán soldin
periodista de 32 años fallecido el
martes en Ucrania en el desempeño de su
trabajo soldin perdió la vida en chasis
billar una localidad cercana
Vázquez escenario de cruentos combates
desde hace 10 meses
conocemos los riesgos asumimos los
riesgos y siempre es increíblemente
difícil cuando las cosas no salen como
esperábamos armar era alguien querido
por sus colegas que estaba
increíblemente comprometido con la
historia la canciller francesa se sumó
al tributo
quiero rendir homenaje no solo a su
coraje sino también al trabajo que hizo
esencial para que sepamos la verdad
tanto en Ucrania como en otros lugares
por su parte kiev responsabilizó a Moscú
por la muerte del periodista y el
parlamento ucraniano lamentó en un breve
comunicado lo sucedido
la zona en que murió Armando es blanco
constante de bombardeos rusos y el
kremlin hizo un llamado a investigar el
suceso
sugiero no creer no tomar la palabra a
los representantes ucranianos porque
quiero recordarles declaraciones
bastante recientes de representantes
ucranianos sobre la decisión de prohibir
el ingreso de periodistas a las áreas
adyacentes a las zonas de contacto
con solding Ya son tres los decesos de
periodistas franceses en la Guerra de
Ucrania según reporteros Sin fronteras
el número total asciende a 10 desde el
inicio de la invasión rusa